one of my heroes one of everyone's
Heroes you got to work with the Michael
J fox he got to work with you but um
I can't imagine that I mean was was that
up just awesome total fun job show up in
New York City where I was from and easy
to work with oh my gosh dream like total
you were so young here too oh yeah this
is all like I don't know I was
he's older than you right a few years
not that much he looked like an infant
in that movie yeah if you look back he
looks like he's so young looking well he
was on that TV show Family times right I
love Family Ties you guys did you ever
watch that
I didn't but I'm that's I've seen a
little bit together for a million years
is that the theme song and I bet we'll
be together
for a million more yeah I knew all of it
my brother and I used to sing I used to
love Family Ties but go ahead
yeah I remember watching the moment
where he's watching you drink water from
the water oh yeah and it's just the most
sexual kids drive fantastic and you just
look over at him and I'm like oh my god
with the 1980s haircut and the blue
eyeliner lots of blue yeah yeah felt
very 80s I mean you did a lot of
memorable movies like Ruthless People
working with Bette Midler and I remember
the scene with the you're talking to
Danny DeVito John reinheld on the phone
and the with the hamburger and it sounds
like you're getting tortured or whatever
right and you know you're screaming it
looks like it was so much fun on that
one too it was that was those were the
Zucker brothers and Jim Abrams younger
brothers do um Kentucky Fried Movie and
airplane an airplane and top secret were
they great to work with so much fun all
you did was laugh and improvise
you know I don't know
I don't notify as much back then that's
like much more now current right the
thing to do everybody's improvising yeah
Ruthless People is based on an oh Henry
short story called like
Ransom oh I can't remember what it is
but anyway the writing was so tight
because it's Oh Henry but that's why I
think that movie works so well